las víctimas de los atentados de marzo
de 2016 en Bélgica se preparan para
declarar ante un tribunal; luigan agua
siempre disfruto de las orillas de los
estanques de Bruselas pero desde hace
seis años y medio llega a contemplarla
solo el 22 de marzo de 2016 su pareja a
mí murió en el metro de malbec a la
espera del inicio del juicio por los
atentados de Bruselas Luis ya sabe lo
que dirá cuando se ha llamado a declarar
es un mensaje de homenaje a mí para
decir la maravillosa persona que era y
la suerte que tuve de conocerla
y también toda la rabia y el
resentimiento que tengo hacia los
individuos que perpetraron este acto
no muy lejos de mí ese día estaba rana
quien sobrevivió junto con su abogada
esta mujer de origen sueco quiso
informarse sobre el procedimiento
judicial de hecho el tribunal penal está
lleno de sorpresas en el de los ataques
yana tenía más de cinco meses de
embarazo y quedó con graves quemaduras
ahora le gustaría que su hija pudiera
actuar dentro de la parte civil sí hay
que hacer esta petición el trauma
transgeneracional es una realidad
no sabemos aún Cuáles puedan ser las
dificultades para ella también cuando
crezca ella también estuvo allí y si yo
no hubiera sobrevivido ella tampoco lo
había hecho entonces sin duda es también
una víctima directa
antiguo empleado del aeropuerto de
Bruselas Felipe estaba en Primera fila
cuando los dos terroristas suicidas se
hicieron explotar para preparar el
juicio este informático de formación no
dudó en tomar cursos de derecho a
diferencia del juicio de París en el que
deliberaron magistrados profesionales en
Bélgica será un Jurado popular el que
emita El veredicto
[Música]
podría causar enormes problemas hasta
llegar a la anulación del juicio por
falta de jurados Y eso sería aún más
graves
para este juicio extraordinario se
convocó a cientos de ciudadanos belgas
al final se formará un Jurado de 12
miembros y 24 suplentes